- The Philpotts are at odds,
merging their different design styles.
And, before the break, Cass and Ted
each gave opening statements,
defending why their space needs to
kind of speak to their needs.
And Cass wants a tranquil reading room,
and Ted wants a game room to
entertain family and friends.
Well, Ted, we wanted to
bring in reinforcements.
He has a surprise witness to
help him drive his case home.
Mikel?
- Yes, Ted, go ahead and tell us
who our surprise witness is.
- I brought in the big gun.
I brought in the woman
who really makes the
decisions in the house,
and that's our 15 year old daughter.
(crowd laughing)
(crowd cheering)
- Is this Elle?
- It is Elle Philpott.
Come on out.
- Elle!
(crowd cheering)
Oh, Elle!
Oh, Elle, I've been so
excited to meet you.
Doing my research on you,
you are such a good girl.
- Thank you, thank you.
- She is a good girl.
- Oh my God.
- I don't know if I like this though.
It's not fair.
- Yeah, it does seem like
you're siding with dad on this one.
- Speak your truth, Elle.
Live in the truth.
- Yeah.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I love you, but I have to defend dad,
because I think we need a game room,
so I can hang out with my friends,
and you're always saying
you want me home more.
- Okay, Ted, that was
a pretty smooth move.
I mean, God-
- Thank you.
- [Drew] You really brought
down the gavel with Elle.
- I wanna win.
- I think it's only fair that
I bring in a surprise witness.
And I think I'm gonna do it-
- [Mikel] Well, who is your witness?
- I'm gonna bring in a professional.
- Oh!
- None other than interior designer
and co-host of Queer Eye, Bobby Berk.
- Oh, you playing dirty.
(crowd cheering)
- I'm really excited,
because also there is another
detail here you need to know.
Ted has this diver's helmet
that is his grandfather's,
but I feel like you really wanna make it
a statement piece.
And, just speaking as a woman,
this, I don't think I would
want as a centerpiece in design,
but the sentimentality
really speaks to me,
so I'm curious as to what
Bobby has to say about it.
Let's roll the tape.
- Hey, Drew and Mikel,
it's Bobby Berk here,
and I 100 percent object
to the divine helmet
Ted wants to add to this room.
I love a piece that tells a story,
but this is not the story
that we wanna tell in this room.
This space should be a sanctuary,
and not a reminder of stressful
stuff like battleships.
So, lady and gentlemen of the jury,
I implore you to side
with Cass on this issue.
The helmet is not it.
(crowd cheering)
- Overruled, overruled, overruled.
We need to throw that out.
That's overruled.
- I have to agree with Bobby on that one,
and he is a fantastic expert.
(upbeat music)